bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 17 juin
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction de télé fils voici les
principaux titres qui seront développés
au cours de la prochaine demi heure le
bac 2015 est lancée et comme à chaque
fois c est sur l'épreuve de philosophie
que les candidats de toutes les séries
devaient plancher ce matin reportage à
suivre dans un établissement de clients
le préfet lance le conseil des
institutions musulmanes devil in un
organe censé favoriser le dialogue entre
les représentants des communautés
islamiques du département et l'état et
qui pourrait se généraliser dans le
reste de la france
elysée local c'est le nom de l'opération
lancée par la librairie le pavé du canal
à montigny le bretonneux neuf auteurs du
territoire invités pour échanger avec
les habitants dès ce vendredi les
détails tout à l'heure en plateau avec
son responsable notamment invité donc de
cette édition
le baccalauréat c'est parti pour six
jours d'épreuves jusqu'au 24 juin pour
les écrits et pour débuter la redoutable
séance de philosophie côté littéraire
les étudiants pouvaient planché sur
cette question respecter tout être
vivant est ce un devoir moral côté
scientifique est cette thématique la
politique échappe-t-elle à l'exigence de
vérité et c'est cette question que nous
sommes allez vous poser aujourd'hui dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
cette structure la vérité est toujours
importante
il ya beaucoup de marins songe dans la
politique tous les politiciens disent
n'importe quoi pour être populaire alors
que c'est parfaitement ce qu'il passe à
huy centre convoite
c'est le politiquement correct on veut
pas effrayer ou c'est la course
poursuite au au quota de de popularité
et tout ça ok c'est disent la vérité ils
savent très bien que aux prochaines
élections on va être papa heureux je
connais le sujet parce que mon fils a
passé ce matin donc comme l'a déjà
déploré
non ben oui oui dans les faits et non
dans le temps le font croire
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement les
politiques sont pas très crédibles le
mélange absolu ça n'aurait pas été le
cas
sincèrement oui parce que pour moi la
politique d'un pays c'est ce qui forme
un pays et si on forme un pays sûr là
sur un mensonge bas malheureusement
après tout le reste
bah ça vaut rien et ce matin ce sont les
lycéens des séries générales qui ont
travaillé ils étaient plus de 680 mille
en france dont 10 1399 yvelinois sur
cette épreuve de philosophie lé thème
vous l'avez entendu art politique morale
retour sur cette matinée des preuves
avec mélanie poker et yolaine thorez une
oeuvre d'art at elle toujours un sens à
respecter tout être vivant health un
devoir moral ou encore suis je sais que
mon passé a fait de moi
voici quelques-uns des sujets proposés
aux candidats cette année à la sortie de
l'épreuve
les avis sont mitigés les sujets il
était assez inattendue est assez dur
quoi c'est le bac ça va je pense que je
me suis bien débrouillé je suis tombé
sur un sujet qui m'a assez inspiré quand
même
ok je suis contrainte c'était cool ça
c'est par contre c'est bien c'est tombé
sur suggéré visez donc c'est bien le
discours était pourtant bien différents
trois heures et demie plus tôt julien
partait défaitiste il est 7h30
il s'apprête ainsi que 240 autres
candidats des séries générales à entrer
dans ce lycée guyancourt toi ô bô
baghlan j'étais déjà dans la limite de
ce qu'ils vont redoubler donc je pense
que ce sera simplement c'est pas très
grave ce n'est pas un dossier très
où donc je crois que ce sera bien pour
moi j'ai révisé toutes les citations
tout ce que m'a dit mon professeur on a
eu des courants plus pour pour ceux qui
voulaient y avait du coup ça va je pense
que je suivrai quatre heures d'épreuve
pour restituer leurs connaissances à
répartis dans 27 salles et surveillé par
deux professeurs ou membre du personnel
de l'établissement
l'organisation effectivement a démarré
il ya deux semaines on à la préparation
des salles on a également l'affectation
des élèves dans les salles
on a les surveillants à trouver qui sont
nos surveillants nos professeurs à nous
qui surveille et on a la particularité
nous cette année d'accueillir d'autres
établissements en centre décrit cette
année pas de problème au niveau des
sujets les intitulés de secours sont
restés au coffre-fort
si la philosophie est passé les épreuves
du baccalauréat sont loin d'être
terminées encore six jours d'épreuves et
certains l'ont bien compris
les résultats seront connus le lundi 7
juillet allez courage aux lycéens
à la veille du début de la période de
ramadan le préfet des yvelines installé
le 6000 conseil des institutions
musulmanes des yvelines une volonté des
associations et qui fait suite à une
circulaire du 11 mars dernier du premier
ministre manuel valls après les
dramatiques événements de janvier sur
paris et sa région
le conseil des institutions musulmanes
devraient se réunir une fois par mois et
une fois par trimestre en présence du
préfet est différents thèmes abordés les
lieux de culte l'organisation de l'aïd
et les actions entre islam et
citoyenneté sur le terrain et quelles
sont les difficultés que rencontrent les
associations musulmanes qui je le
rappelle aujourd'hui une association
composée 150 citoyens français musulmans
qui vivent leur culte dans la république
et donc nous avons d'abord le thème
citoyenneté république et islam c'est un
thème transversal sur laquelle il faut
que nous avancions ensemble et puis si
la somme de thèmes qui est dans
l'exercice du culte sur la création de
mosquées sur l'aïd sur voilà donc tous
ces thèmes là qui interpelle les
associations au moment de leur revente
fait et comment on peut apporter des
réponses dans le cadre encore une fois
de la république et des lois et
règlements en vigueur donc il s'agit pas
de se substituer aux deux sessions mais
de les accompagner
ça revient sur de dialogue de
concertation et ensuite ça vise à
moderniser une certaine manière de dix
ans de poser les problèmes et d'apporter
les sociétés solution de plus approprié
des fois les élus locaux sont devant
certains passent par rapport à des
situations qui leur sont propres et donc
là le shimmy apporte sa consigne de sa
contribution avec une confiance du mur
qui permet de prendre de super 8
millions qui seront pas simples à
prendre le golf national à saint quentin
en yvelines s'est engagé depuis
plusieurs années dans une politique de
gestion de l'eau éco-responsable samedi
dernier une visite a été proposée pour
le public pour découvrir tous les
dispositifs qui ont été pris en
conséquence cette opération s'inscrit
dans le cadre de parole de jardiniers
manifestations qui se déroulent
actuellement dans tout le département le
reportage de sephora namani et de maxime
le même entretenir le parcours de façon
écoresponsable une priorité du golf
national qui proposait une visite pour
faire découvrir au public les moyens
utilisés pour optimiser la gestion de
l'eau sur le golf
la première des choses à faire c'est de
raisonner les graminées qu'on va
utiliser puisque c'est quand même le
choix qu'ont effectué en amont et en
fonction des graminées qu'on va amener
implantée sur le site on n'aura pas du
tout les mêmes besoins en nous plus la
planète se réchauffe tu
on aura affaire à des périodes de
sécheresse sans doute longue et donc il
est important dès à présent d'importer
et et d'installer des graminées qui
seront à même de de faire face ou de
résister à ces nouvelles problématiques
et à ces stress stress hydrique et
stress de température
privilégiez un gazon qui consomment peu
d'eau le coupé à bonne hauteur et
l'arroser avec parcimonie sont des
techniques suffisamment maîtrisée par le
golfe pour être efficace sans perturber
le jeu des golfeurs on arrive à un
résultat équivalent pour le golfeur le
golf est tout aussi beau peut-être
différent peut-être qu'il ya un petit
peu plus d'herbe d'herbe marron jaune
mais ça c'est en saison d'été uniquement
des kirs plein hiver s'est ouvert 900
arroseurs concourt actuellement à
l'alimentation en eau du parcours des
travaux sont prévus après l'open de
france dans un mois pour moderniser le
système de drainage et s'équiper de 2000
arroseurs les arroseurs change sont de
plus en plus performants on a des têtes
de plus en plus petit avec des jets
qu'on peut gérer au mieux pour des
brumisations pour et puis du coup on va
pouvoir via les deux mises arroseurs
qu'on va implanter
on va pouvoir procéder à des arrosages
beaucoup plus et beaucoup mieux
circonscrit et donc pour une efficacité
accrue et des économies d'eau à terme
aujourd'hui soixante mille mètres cubes
d'eau sont nécessaires à arroser les 140
hectares du golf national soit une
économie réalisée de quarante mille
mètres cubes en quelques années
depuis la signature par le golf de la
charte de l'environnement et pour les
amateurs de golf bien sûr l'open
national qui va débuter dans quelques
quinze jours le 2 juillet puisqu'il est
question de sport justement un mot pour
saluer la performance des gymnastes
d'elancourt maurepas les deux équipes de
gymnastique artistique féminine était en
finale des championnats de france à
saint-etienne
si en catégorie fédérale 2 elle termine
à la 13e place en division critérium 2
benjamines elles décrochent l'or tout
simplement invités de ce journal à
présent on va parler culture avec leurs
hangars un bon soir vous êtes le
responsable de la librairie le pavé du
canal à montigny-le-bretonneux et
bonsoir apolline amis
vous êtes responsable littérature bd
jeunesse de ce même établissement
vendredi 19 juin va débuter cette
opération lisez locale ça se terminera
le lendemain le 20 juin le pavec il va
ouvrir l ses portes à neuf auteurs de la
région
l'idée c'est de valoriser la richesse
locale ce qui n'était pas fait jusqu'à
présent
donc il n'était pas fait totalement donc
on a énormément d'auteurs locaux qui
viennent nous voir qui nous sollicitent
à longueur d'année et fort de cet
engouement là on s'est dit pourquoi pas
tous les réunir sur une journée pilat en
fait y en avait quand même suffisamment
pour faire ça sur deux jours donc on
s'est dit allez on va ouvrir la
librairie à ses auteurs qui ont aussi du
talon et qu'il faut qu'on fasse
reconnaître par le public le public et
c'est une demande aussi peut-être du
public est ce que le public connaît ses
auteurs ou alors elle s'intéresse un peu
à ces écrivains jouer ça s'intéressent
aux et bien sûr à tout ce qui est local
et tout ce qui est aussi familial parce
que souvent ces sons ce sont des gens
qui habitent la ville nouvelle qui
travaille sinon à la ville nouvelle
donc c'est des gens oui qui sont connus
et reconnus parmi la population
on va évoquer les différents ouvrages et
à neuf auteurs comment vous avez fait le
choix déjà justement ben on a voulu en
fait pas trop ciblée sur une thématique
particulière donc on a ouvert un peu de
jeunesse un peu de littérature un peu de
vie pratique un peu de sport aussi voilà
on a vraiment voulu ouvert ouvrir le
panel à toutes ces sollicitudes qu'on
avait durant l'année donc voilà et sur
le secteur jeunesse justement peut-être
en parlait il ya une hauteur qui est
professeur d'anglais au lycée descartes
à montigny-le-bretonneux
elle a écrit un livre jeunesse bilingue
tout à fait qui s'appelle le renard sur
l'aubrac donc c'est un livre destiné aux
enfants qui est plutôt un documentaire
donc qui parle de là
vie du renard la manière dont ils
s'alimentent et c est dans cet ouvrage
l'enfant peut découvrir le texte à la
fois en français et en anglais
elle en a écrit également sur la vache
enfin voilà qui scella viendrait que ces
deux ouvrages samedi prochain et ce sera
donc à découvrir aux pavés du canal en
tout neuf auteurs qui ont des profils
très différents si ce n'est ce point
commun d'habiter saint quentin en
yvelines ils écrivent tous dans des
registres très très large écrivent pas
forcément sûr on l'a vu avec la jeunesse
mais pas forcément sur l'histoire de 55
non justement non il y en a pas un seul
qui avec lille a enfin pour le coup sûr
50 ans mais ils ont tous raconter leurs
histoires à eux mais pas forcément sur
la ville nouvelle
en fait le fait comme enfin le trait
commun de tous et toutes ces personnes
c'est que soit ils habitent soit ils
vivent ici
bernard delattre par exemple qui a écrit
sur la chine qui est sur l'histoire sa
passion l'histoire de la chine on
l'avait reçue d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
alexia paix traquini monteyne et qui a
écrit un roman d'anticipation 2040 le
dernier jour je vais pas vous demander
de nous donner la liste en entier ni de
vous fâcher avec personne mais est-ce
qu'il y en a 1 particulièrement qui a
retenu votre attention dans le sport
automobile voilà c'est une belle
découverte pour moi c'est un beau livre
j'ai trouvé de monsieur bitume donc
voila c'était une belle découverte
rainer berak et une autobiographie tout
à fait même de son parcours y at-il en
plus d'auteurs pas forcément son niveau
local mais globalement aujourd'hui tout
le monde peut écrire et est ce que
justement ça rend plus difficile le fait
de trouver le bon roman il ya tellement
d'auteur oui mais on fait forcément une
sélection qu'enfin il ya déjà une
sélection en avant
de prendre ces neuf auteurs là donc oui
à quand même assez sollicités durant
l'année avec des auteurs un peu
hétéroclite mais vraiment de l'édition a
changé de plus en plus de gens se
lancent en ayant une activité
oui c'est ça c'est à compte d'auteur
souvent faim les gens se lancent alors
entre une diffusion soit personnel ou
familial et puis souvent ils tentent
leur chance en librairie et viennent
nous voir avec leurs ouvrages donc
d'abord on le lit ensuite si ça nous
plaît on fait soit une rencontre comme
celle ci où des rencontres tout au long
de l'année au secteur jeunesse
voici plus particulièrement oui tout à
fait il ya des gens qui écrivent et qui
s'associe avec des gens qui illustre
plutôt et c'est vrai que c'est un
domaine assez foisonnant et les gens
aiment bien raconter des histoires aux
enfants donc pourquoi pas les mettre par
écrit
donc c'est un peu l'idée de s'auto
diffuser de s'autoéditer de montrer un
peu à tout le monde ce qu'on fait quand
l'elysée locales ces langues l'opération
qui débute ce vendredi au palais du
canal à montigny le bretonneux en
organisant ce genre d'opération vous
souhaitez aussi vous démarquer ou créer
l'événement aussi sur votre vie les
glissements pu faire venir le plus
mauvais qu'il ya une vie culturelle dans
cette ville nouvelle et que voilà que ça
foisonne et que nous aussi on fait
partie de cette ville et que voilà on va
être vraiment un marqueur essentiel de
la vie culturelle de la ville et faire
venir les gens dans cette librairie de
quartier justement la librairie de
quartier vous y rendez vous encore
souvent c'est notre question du jour et
on poursuit l'entretien juste après oui
oui bien sûr parce que nous on lit
beaucoup et
et on est très comment dire et j'en ai
très papier en fait on est très beau cas
non pourquoi ce que j'ai lu pas je vais
à la librairie du canal mots j'aime bien
c'est plus petit et en plus on a des
bons conseils
on peut être conseillé et puis on peut
on peut
mieux manipuler les livres non non ce
que j'en ai pas dans mon quartier déjà
pendant tout simplement
oui et c'est souvent pour pour prendre
soin des romances reçoit des livres pour
les cours à la fac c'est beaucoup plus
sympa on en trouvera des conseils c'est
pas
une surface de but sud le mexique n'est
ce pas trop j'y vois là j'ai rendez vous
pour une signature vendredi
il vaut mieux qu'il ya un peu moins de
choix mais que ce soit plus visible d'un
point de vue d'ensemble plutôt que des
nouilles et sur la quantité comme
l'internet par exemple on sait pas où
regarder
les sauteurs qui s'y rendent aussi
forcément dans ses librairies de
quartier pour le coup la fréquentation
de cet établissement justement vous
l'avez repris a pas si longtemps que ça
c'est sa longue retenue alors que tout à
quel bilan vous en faite c'est de ces
quelques mois est ce que l'activité
fonctionne bien oui ça progresse
toujours et puis je sais à ses fins et
même très positif quoi le retour
d'expérience me montre hui qu on a tout
à fait notre place nous livre
indépendant sur le conseil sur justement
ce genre d'événements culturels qu'on
peut nous apporter
donc non c'est vraiment un chiffre au
niveau national en 2013 22% du marché de
la vente de livres détail était détenu
par les librairies indépendantes
justement donc la place malgré les
inquiétudes malgré internet malgré les
grandes surfaces vous réussissez à vous
maintenir oui tout à fait c'est pas
comme les disquaires vous n'allez pas
disparu normalement non de vrai nom
puisque les gens sont toujours attirés
par un conseil parce que voilà il
ils ont besoin d'un rapport humain et
puis nous aussi on a besoin de cet
échange la coi pour que nous on puisse
aussi à prendre des gens il ya aussi ce
fait là est ce que des ajustements qui
ont été faits depuis vous avez appris la
librairie je pense aux activités qui
sont proposées on a essayé d'ouvrir un
peu plus bas par exemple la livraison à
vélo avec cet entrepreneur local lui
aussi voilà on a certaines choses on a
essayé de renouer certains liens avec
l'université avec nos institutions aussi
toutes les institutions le plein on
essaye de renouer certain lien et puis
toutes les tous les comités d'entreprise
qui qui sont qui foisonnent aussi à 50
ans il faut aussi que qu'on travaille
sur c'est ce côté là et des événements a
annoncé peut-être lors des événements
oui on a
durant l'été la mi juillet du 14 juillet
au 31 juillet on alizés en short donc
une opération jeunesse menée par le cnl
on va accueillir des jeunes
on va faire un petit coin dédié
uniquement pour la jeunesse soit environ
nous devons pouvoir s'installer
calmement on va leur passer des textes à
la rentrée on va on va proposer une
présentation de toute la rentrée
littéraire donc sur une soirée le
vendredi 4 septembre en soirée
donc nous là on est en train de
travailler justement sur cette rentrée
là donc on présentera soit enfin ce soit
nos clients comme à nos collectivités
tous les bouquins qui nous nous ont plu
durant durant l'été et on fera une
présentation sur toute la moisson qui va
pouvoir exister sur la rentrée qu'on est
pour vous rendre dans cette librairie
est un bon prétexte aussi c'est la fête
des pères voilà et vous avez ramené
quelques ouvrages on va conclure avec
vous conseiller le livre donc andy terra
turna la facture de jonas carmes sonne
donc c est un homme qui reçoit un petit
peu plus on voit la couverture voilà qui
ressort à jour une facture d'un montant
d'à peu près six cent mille euros
il n'y a pas de justification il connaît
pas l'établissement qui a fait cette
facture et après renseignement en fait
cette facture correspond au prix du
bonheur et de la vie qu'il a eu une vie
plutôt une plutôt une belle vie et voilà
donc c'est une réflexion serait ce que
le est ce que le bonheur aurais tu un
coup c'est assez drôle c'est un peu
grinçant voilà un livre à faire
découvrir aux papas dans un autre genre
en beaucoup plus sanglant naîtrait
inconséquent aussi voilà plus d'un an
que ça soit créé un très gros donc c'est
le nouveau franck thilliez il était
assez attendu pandémie à franck thilliez
a travaillé en collaboration avec avec
l'institut pasteur pour écrire ce livre
on retrouve des signes mort dans un parc
et après examen il s'avère qu'ils sont
tous contaminés par le virus de la
grippe h1n1 est également le quai
d'orsay est le quai des orfèvres pardon
est également touchée par ce virus donc
ça roule enquête un petit peu difficile
c'est vraiment très intéressant c'est
c'est vraiment documenter ses mollets
ggc
deux sanglants mais les amateurs de
franck thilliez le savent déjà ce n'est
pas pas dépressif voilà pour les papas
pas dépressif et qui aiment voilà les
séries face à higuain nombreux comme le
dit le titre si vous aimez les séries ce
livre est fait pour vous dans ce livre
on va retrouver toutes les séries
actuelles et plus ancien nom il ya des
conseils également pour en découvrir de
nouvelles si vous aimez game of thrones
par exemple vous aimerez telle série etc
c'est un livre de référence sur les
séries il ya pas mal de secrets de
tournage de belles illustrations voilà
points les papas passionnés de séries
très bien et puis un dernier et un
dernier c'est une bd c'est un une bd un
peu particulière elle est accompagnée je
vois qui a affiché un vinyle avait d'un
vinyle c'est une histoire du rock and
roll tout simplement quand les papas
branger voilà tout à fait très bien et
bien merci pour ces conseils à la veille
de la fête des pères j'en profite pour
passer un message
si j'avais été ouvrage qui pourrait
m'intéresser merci à tous les deux des
trois menus ça sur ce plateau lisez
local c'est le nom de l'opération qui
débute vendredi
éducation à présent culture aussi à
maurepas les élèves du collège louis
pergaud se sont initiés au phénomène pop
songs c'est une performance musicale des
plus originales et qui nécessitent du
rythme de la cohésion de groupe et des
gobelets en plastique orly à domicile
et
m
phénomène musical sur le web le caps on
débarque désormais maurepas et 450
élèves du collège louis pergaud se sont
réunis ce matin pour interpréter leur
propre version de la chanson when i'm
gone devenu culte auprès des adolescents
inspiré d'une comédie musicale
américaine
le cap song consiste à shooter tout en
tapant dans ses mains et on va t'on la
mesure avec un gobelet en plastique
une initiative proposée par le
professeur d'éducation musicale du
collège chaque grandes vacances je
réfléchis toujours quel port projet va
vraiment intéressés tous ces jeunes
parce que quand même se renouveler et
une amie m'a parlé de du cap sont donc
je suis allé voir sur internet
ils ont appris chaque semaine depuis
octobre donc on a passé quasiment
l'année dessus à raison de dix minutes
parcours d'abord lentement puis on a
accéléré non ça n'a pas été difficile
puis franchement il était très très
motivés donc
c'est vraiment ça fait vraiment plaisir
quoi il suit bien le projet et sont
toujours partants ça c'est de leur
qualité ce qui était vraiment important
c'est que en fait les élèves comprennent
que dans un groupe que le groupe qui
fait le cap ce quel que soit celui que
vous venez de voir les plus petits en
place
dans le groupe il est impossible de
laisser un élève qui le fait pas bien
ils ont été obligés de s'entraîner et ça
c'est très très important
chaque élève réalisation jamais en
changer pour éviter de briser la chaîne
de solidarité exercice et donc amusant
mais il permet surtout la prendre le
rythme travail en groupe c'était bien
parce que du coup ça faisait un esprit
d'équipé parce que même cela qui
arrivait pas on était obligé de les
aider parce que si on a un qui arrive
pas après il ya toute la chaîne qui
décalé et du coup ça nous a poussés à
avoir à s'entre aider les uns les autres
on a beaucoup travaillé on a du travail
aussi à la maison et tous à travailler
avec les élèves et mais c'était bien
parce qu'on sait tous s'amuser il faut
avoir le rythme déjà il faut il faut
être faut partager tous avec le nouveau
projet musical autour d'un autre thème
verra le jour à la rentrée prochaine
m
bientôt
à
bravo et on termine ce journal avec la
première édition de la fête de la nature
c'était à bois d'arcy le conseil
municipal des jeunes là aussi ce sont
eux qui ont été sollicités ils ont
piloté cet événement yolaine thorez la
nature au coeur de la fête
une première à bois d'arcy trois jours
durant lesquels l'environnement était à
l'honneur une priorité pour le maire
depuis le début de son mandat sa commune
est d'ailleurs sur le point d'avoir sa
première fleur rouge
on a planté plus de 70000 bulbes sur sur
bonnart 6 et puis on a appuyé on a
soutenu énormément de projets avec les
jeunes du code du cmj du conseil
municipal des jeunes
on a énormément soutenu des projets
d'environnement d'écologie de potager
partagé
et puis cette première fête de la nature
qui est apparemment une réussite
encadré et appuyé par la commune c'est
le conseil municipal des jeunes qui a
piloté cette première fête de la nature
ont jeunes se sont investis dans ce
projet en fait on a voulu mettre en
place ce projet pour mobiliser toute la
population de la simone de population on
va protéger notre nature notre
environnement
plusieurs stands étaient proposés aux
visiteurs enjeux de l'eau organisée par
versailles grand parc un jeu sur le
recyclage et l'huile de palme est aussi
de quoi se désaltérer sous le soleil de
plomb avec ses jus de fruits bio
je pense que c'est bien c'est bien
d'encourager ce genre d'initiative la
nature le recyclage tout ça c'est des
valeurs qui vont devenir de plus en plus
intéressantes et il faut les encourager
l'endroit n'était pas choisie au hasard
le canal paysager de la croix bonnet
petit coin de nature au coeur de la
ville une dernière information qui
concerne bois d'arcy justement la ville
organise une réunion publique de
concertation sur le projet d'aménagement
des terrains de la société fujifilm ce
vendredi 19 juin à 18h en salle des
fêtes les terrains qui seront libérés en
2016 par cette entreprise un projet
privé va voir le jour l'ancienne équipe
municipale envisagées 450 logements la
nouvelle s'y oppose et veut mettre
l'accent sur l'aménagement paysager
vendredi 19 juin la réunion autour de ce
projet fin du journal rendez vous demain
aux horaires habituels est tout de suite
ces kiosques le magazine de la culture
il sera très largement question de la
fête de la musique de ce week end très
belle soirée